momento de actualizar las noticias
económicas con Daniela Blandón Daniela
Buenos días para usted Hola Buenos días
Ángela ya ha estado en los titulares de
todo este tema el llamado a la calma de
Joe biden ayudó a los inversionistas del
silicon que pero no mucho al mercado
bursátil usted nos cuenta Sí señora pero
antes que toda una noticia de último
minuto 6,4% se ubicó la inflación de
Estados Unidos en febrero Este es un
dato muy importante del que todo el
mundo estaba pendiente hoy y ya veremos
Por qué es tan clave en la jornada pues
mire como la historia que le tengo es la
siguiente doctor girson es el dueño de
una startup de Inteligencia artificial
para radiología y tiene 65 empleados en
California tiene un crecimiento de su
negocio del 200% anual y hoy ayuda a
generar informes para más de un millón
de pacientes al mes Pues el empresario
tomó un respiro cuando se enteró de que
le sería devuelto todo su dinero de este
banco
como fundador de una startup te anticipa
si tratas de resolver muchos riesgos
pero diría que las últimas 72 horas han
sido una versión extrema de eso sin
saber si la empresa que has construido
durante cinco años iba a desaparecer de
la noche a la mañana como resultado de
algo creo impredecible el colapso del
banco fue muy duro incluso para mi
familia no parecía que estuviera
sucediendo fue muy difícil pero me
alegro de que pudimos superarlo Así que
ahora puedo estar feliz por eso pero en
su momento definitivamente me estaba
enfermando Físicamente
pero como le decía el mercado bursátil
en general sí ha sufrido Sí señora Ya lo
vamos a tratar más en detalles pero le
voy a dar un ejemplo Y es que este
colapso generó temor sobre que de que
pueda sobre que pueda existir una nueva
crisis financiera y eso repercute
directamente por ejemplo en los precios
del petróleo el lunes los valores del
barril de brent y wti cayeron a su nivel
más bajo desde principios de enero y de
diciembre respectivamente y hoy bajan
más de dos dólares ambos están en menos
de 80 dólares por barril
hablemos de Cómo opera el mercado
accionario entonces las bolsas asiáticas
ya están descansando pero después de
fuertes pérdidas que se acercaron al 3%
en donde los principales perdedores
fueron los bancos de Japón que llegaron
a desplomarse en hasta un 8% en Estados
Unidos a pesar de las variaciones
tímidas en sus principales índices del
lunes First con sede en San Francisco se
deslizó en más del 60 por ciento y otros
como Western aliens y key corp o Paco
estebank cayeron entre el 20 y el 47% su
acción según el caso ya que muchos de
ellos son vistos como los siguientes en
esta lista de quiebras en Europa la
tendencia es al alza Este es un momento
de encrucijada para los inversionistas
porque por un lado está este temor de
crisis que está empujando las acciones a
la baja pero por el otro lado está el
hecho de que todo este lío puede hacer
que la reserva Federal suavice la subida
de tasas y eso beneficia al mercado
bursátil Por eso podríamos esperar para
el día de hoy una apertura al alza de
Wall Street ya que la inflación se está
desacelerando 6,6% en febrero venía de
6,4% en enero y eso lo que hace es bajar
los expectativas de inflación y que la
fe pues sea más suave en la toma de
decisiones bien vamos a tener un
descanso de este tema y le quiero
preguntar por otra noticia Que seguro va
a tener repercusiones especialmente en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
aprobó un enorme proyecto petrolero en
Alaska Claro que sí bastante polémico
porque esta es una medida que ha sido
rechazada por los ecologistas ellos
acusan a la administración biden de
romper sus promesas sobre la lucha
contra el cambio climático y auguran una
batalla judicial en este en este asunto
la Esfera política de Alaska en cambio
Si defendió este proyecto por sus
beneficios económicos pero todo nos lo
cuenta Ramiro cuevar pererena
el lunes el presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden le dio luz verde al
controvertido proyecto denominado Willow
para aumentar la extracción de petróleo
en Alaska La representante demócrata en
Alaska defendió la medida alegando
beneficios financieros
hice campaña a favor de Willow porque
sabía que lo necesitábamos debemos
invertir el declive económico de Alaska
hoy la administración biden ha tomado la
decisión correcta y antepuesto el
progreso energético real al absolutismo
Willow será ejecutado por el gigante
petrolero conozco Phillips y estiman que
producirá 180.000 barriles por día
ayudará a crear 250.000 empleos y miles
de millones de dólares sin embargo los
ecologistas mostraron oposición y
acusaron a biden de romper sus promesas
sobre la lucha contra el cambio
climático
tratando de apaciguar a la delegación
de las de los combustibles fósiles en el
congreso y esos increíblemente
decepcionante de ver
dice que no solo se preocupa por la
crisis climática sino también por
abordar a la justicia ambiental y
abordar la crisis de extinción y sin
embargo este proyecto exacerbará las
tres crisis
en la misma jornada el gobierno
estadounidense amplió protecciones en
tierras y aguas de Alaska y el mar
Ártico pero los ambientalistas critican
la ambigüedad y prometen una lucha
judicial tras una nueva decepción en
materia ecológica el senador de Alaska
dan Sullivan dijo que la delegación del
Congreso aguarda un desafío legal
inminente y prepara un informe para
defender el proyecto petrolero también
hay noticias de Ucrania Daniela comenzó
el conteo regresivo para que expire el
acuerdo de granos claro desde que Rusia
y Ucrania firmaron esta iniciativa de
granos del mar Negro que es respaldada
por la ONU en Turquía el junio de 2022
se han exportado millones de toneladas
de cereales y otros productos
alimenticios desde esos puertos
ucranianos tres puertos específicamente
y esto ayudó a reducir los precios
mundiales de los alimentos que ya habían
batido niveles récord del año pasado
Pues el próximo 18 de marzo vence este
acuerdo con Naciones Unidas y Turquía
que son los garantes del pacto diciendo
que es posible una extensión sin embargo
Rusia ha pedido una renovación reducida
de apenas 60 días que es la mitad del
plazo anterior cuando se había renovado
en 120 días
para finalizar este seguimiento Daniela
en Reino Unido Hay buenas noticias Pero
agrias porque baja el desempleo pero
escasean los trabajadores pues la tasa
de desempleo se mantuvo en torno al
Siete con al 3,7% en enero eso es una
buena noticia para la economía que
inclusive llegó a esquivar la recesión
sin embargo cada vez se enfrentan más a
las escasez de personal y vamos a verlo
con un ejemplo Y es que hay un castillo
él Downtown Abi es un prominente
castillo en el sur de Inglaterra que ha
sido protagonista de series de
televisión inclusive ha ganado un emmy y
un globo de oro este sitio como ustedes
pueden verlo tan bonito suele ser
contratado para lujosas bodas pero ya
tuvo que cerrar este negocio principal y
limitarlo a pequeñas recepciones todo
por culpa del brexit Según dice su dueña
la salida británica de la Unión Europea
hizo que las decenas de estudiantes
europeos que trabajaban para ellos en el
verano ya no estén disponibles
escuchemos qué piensa ella
ya no podemos ofrecer bodas de tamaño
sustancial debido al brexit no hay
personal y no podemos organizar una boda
para 120 personas con cuatro personas y
el resto de nosotros dando vueltas es
serio y no sé cuándo va a cambiar
cuando vamos a nuestras agencias
habituales y Tratamos de encontrar
personas no están allí si pedimos 10
pueden aparecer tres hemos ido a todas
las universidades locales no hay nadie a
quien no hayamos preguntado pues mire
este tema lo hablamos por algunos
minutos con nuestra primera invitada del
día y era este tema de grandes medidas
que impulsadora para prácticamente
exportar migrantes y pues no hay un
enfoque humanitario que permita que más
personas lleguen a trabajar al Reino
Unido Así es Ángela y se casaría en este
Castillo ya me casé Ah bueno Yo como no
me he casado sí me casaría en este
Castillo aprovechando bueno Daniela no
más preguntas personales y la espero en
el siguiente seguimiento de economía
gracias a usted aquí nos